아 저희 연식 안녕하세요
중 약해 지금 비난 데스 555
으 에 나시 5 어떠해야
out 해 아우네 주 마 놓았어요
네 에
아마도 에 지금 현실이 아주 앞 바빴습니다
여러가지 이거 뭐야 지금 에 촘 전부 영어로 공부해야 합니다
예 4 에 경제학 정지의 에 5
이걸 놈 은 쎄씨 키키 번째 써 예 아
mens 예요 얘기해 예 되세요
음 저감 최근
그 저희 한국어 본부가
에
그 뒤 요아 에
버드 칼 3 집중 악을
가 볼 수 있습니다
예 다른 것은 다른 국무부 없어요
매일 매일 그 보텍스 듣고 있습니다
아주아주 경우 있습니다
이제 초에 생각에는
에
한국 5
가구 공부하기
에
않아요 제가 한국어 공부 하기 않아요 제가 에 그 재미있는 내용이
근거하고 있습니다
감 부호로 경리는
e 여러가지 근무하고 있습니다 내 제 가 음 전에 에 모르는 것은 많이
지금 에
잘 있어요 가루 초 받았습니다 이렇게 제대 뒤 행복이 배우고 있어 되고
있음 예 네 에
물론 에
언어 공부 시작 한테 그 어려운 내용이 에 내용을 사용
아 수 없습니다 네 네 어 음
시작한 테 더욱 수윤 내용 이수윤
에 주 내용이 듣고 이도
에 아니면
에
토 전 툰 저 에 교제에 에
세영 해야 합니다 그러나 어떤 수중 최 도착하면
에
언어공부 언어공부 아니라
에 다름 손 흥부 하기 4
음 병행
매트 센터 알 밤 병헌씨 병명이
에 어느 으 에 개념 나의 벗 애써야
에 세계문화 세계역사 여러가지
에 그 사람은 에 소개합니다
딱 아주 도요 채 3 그때 특기
돼 음 이 20% 정도 얘기함
알 수 있습니다 그러나 지금 에
여기 이 있는 1기 테
80 90% 에 의해 할 수 있습니다
으 a 아주 재미있어요
지금 어떤 파 깨 용 죽고 새 내 지금 에 어 오늘은 제가 음
6번째 z 있어 예 1 고 1 기 듣기 하고 있습니다
에 4시에서 유명한 저가 pc 라고 ode to oi c 4 트위터 ll
be 에 되고 사람은 작가가
음 다름 프란 스
철학 돈 아까 에 초토화 짜 정확히 야 에 형편이 라고
에
에 2회 ep.2 현 인연
eros 6개 0 여 약 요양 만화 m 많이 따랐습니다
내심 그 에 상권이
애라고 에 브라운스
좀 학자 예 솜
라고 안써 성이라고
채 게재 께 소 에 에 관해서 1월까지 설명하고
이제 그 에 온 더 구도
알고 있습니다 근데 아주 재미있어요
예 4 그전에 에 한국 그 씩
실리 어선은 4 시인 액 씨인 있지 에 이름은 제가
에 개요 역사 잃어버릴 이제 전장이다 쥬나 3가 c
아직 싫어요 여호
취익 아우 거 거지 않습니다
제가 씨가 최신호에 이애 없어요 내 제가
산문 쏘서 역사 4
아주 에
져 합니다 그러나 시와
에 씨에 대해서 에 병이 없어요
에 방법이 없어
근데 그러나 에 마유 끼야 6 위험 미시마 이디어 일본 에 작가 so
에피소드도
그 에 다른 에피소드 다 에 브 랜 스 0 0
4 4 에 말이라고
유명한 에 영농 자가 에 여자가
에 여자가 그 말하고 4
축구 섭니다 t 게 돼 내 그
이 관에서 에 유카 있습니다
육아 육아 육아 같고요 베이
tee
별을 하나 있어요 예 예
4 나비 인데 때라고 유명한
에 11 수 에 디 카 2 와 4 ui 와 ui ui 바 100 급의 돼
그 근데 제가 그 에피소드 더
1일 테 에 4
으 언제나 그
에 재미있는 내용이 많이 증가세 지가 에 지식 없기 때문에 의 db 디아
2 이나 다른 에 것이 에 2 토 에
으 예
안테 올 대상 해도 작약의 전편에 차주 때는 3
여러가지 배우고 있습니다 아주 재미있어
왜 에 그렇기 때문에 제가 한국어 공부 하고
아기 없어요 제가 다른 것은 근거 하기
까 갔지 한국어
조금조금 양상 않습니다
패스 합니다 국민대 4
충북 어려운 거 공부하고 있어요 마세요 네 배
쥬시 더 에 용어로
용어로 다른 것은 공부하고 있습니다
예 돼 너 질 수 있어
예 라고 뉴턴 g
오케이 감사합니다 감사합니다
af 합니다 걔
안녕하세요 안녕 이 되세요 걔 되세요 에 보통 한국으로
아 1명 아 한 판 생화가
카 카 거 네 네가 1 2
워낙 터 남 도 나온 사람 아님 a
되세요 4 la
안녕히 가세요 그렇죠 아멘
5 너 걔
그러나 지금 에 사로
너무 좋아해 게 뭐예요 올 보스 건 서버 돼 있어요
굉장히 예 에 솔 살 오 예
관여해서 욕 먹게 알겠어요
예 4 가졌습니다